gang before we hit the fun button in the
episode let's talk about the good old
middle class famous tour talking
stand-up show play a little ayg with the
crowd it's a good time grab the homies
grab the bozos grab your gal grab your
guy come out and see us we're coming
everywhere yeah guys we're going to be
in denver phoenix salt lake city chicago
chicago late show at it first so sold
out then we're going to be in rosemont
oh baby
then we're going to pittsburgh buffalo
and detroit and june get those tickets
we'll see you there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage sure is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out if they grew
up to be classy yeah if they're just a
big old piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day down here in auntie's
basement she's upstairs doing a little
spring cleaning okay at the neighbors
who was out of town
down the shore a little trouble coming
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of are you
garbage he's international businessman
and my best pal luckily give it up for
kj
kevin james ryan but
we now call him kev
i don't know if i like that i think i
said that last time what's up everybody
just kev thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube as you know those numbers are
true to roof cooking and then obviously
the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
ru garbage sign up get a bunch of bonus
content we got the cribs videos of both
of our houses on there the shore video
got a montego video we got a whole bunch
of [ __ ] on there you can see you get
bonus episodes live streams the whole
nine yards check it out plus the big
storyline the big drama of the season
that hard feelings yeah twists and turns
also fat quartz season two fat quarters
who needs yellowstone when you got that
patreon all the drama you need how about
a nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good we love them you love them
give it up for t-bone mcscruffins toby
mcbuttons what's up dudes hey t-bone
yeah we're going for a daytime emmy on
that patreon dude yeah sweeps week
let's go oh man i like it and gang we
have a very special guest back with us
again today he's a part of the third
timers club oh fourth baby no no no this
is three this is okay okay yeah good
friend of ours family at this point we
like to keep a tight circle yeah we
don't want to know bozo's running around
yeah
the devil you know is better than the
devil you don't i'll tell you that right
now give it up for tom decar
what up boys bully kev good to see ya
i feel like me and him just didn't sit
here for 40 minutes
yeah we were already done with the show
man
drinks milk with dinner it's a wrap
you went over there getting your lip all
bloody
shaking off a cold sore oh it's in a
very very delicate stage oh [ __ ] is it
full-blown what is it
fourth quarter yeah
i'm in the fourth quarter i got a real
nail-biter going with this gold sword
two on two up it's a bad scene yeah it
looks good this year it's in its healing
process it's in recovery it looks angry
it just got out of rehab so that's when
it starts cracking and bleeding and
stuff like that yeah very delicate yeah
you're a real piece of tragedy you know
the stages of herpes yeah he's a doctor
but only for [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
only for dirtbag ailments put a little
butter on it you'd be all right
do you get cold sores no no anything
weird like that uh anything weird like
i'll get like a pimple every once in a
while but impact
yeah i keep it clean good skin i i do my
best it's the booze it kills all the you
know the diseases they get
cured myself of gonorrhea yeah it uh
sterilizes you you know no skin tags no
i have like a little uh what is it a
mole or whatever back here a bowl or a
cyst i think it's a mole it's got like
uh you know it's like brown or whatever
that's a mole right yeah
i don't know let me ask them
how often you going to the doctor oh
never never right kidding me i don't
know health insurance me and him are
come from a very similar point when's
the last time you had a checkup oh uh
12th grade physical yeah
what the [ __ ]
yeah he didn't get held back 12 years
yeah that's right yes he was 20 30 a.m
uh and i should probably go my [ __ ]
hurts all the time that's all right
that's the drinking too yeah yeah she's
running around with the check engine
light on yeah yeah yeah that's all right
i went to the i got dental insurance so
i've i've been i got my wisdom teeth
taken out finally i had two i still got
two left wait you have dental insurance
and not health insurance yeah that's a
real tragedy
it's a scam it's pretty crazy it's like
having a boat not a car i figure if
there's anything pressing i can throw
the dental insurance at them you know
if there's any
[Laughter]
my neck's connected to my chest and fix
my broken arm if i go to the dentist i'm
like hey by the way my [ __ ] is
currently [ __ ] up you want me to take
a peek start taking your pants off
it's a cleaning you're here for a
cleaning where did you get that gown
how did you get that gal i could put a
little fluoride on it if you want
here comes the thirsty
trying to get away with that going to an
emergency room with that in a
blockbuster car trying to try to get
your one of these has got to do
something
i got a dave and buster's cart in here
i do have a david buster's car popping
do you have a damon buster's car wallet
right now yeah
i'm not losing those points you kidding
me
if i am at a comedy club with a date
like in a mall i if i if this is a good
time after a show it's it's my workout
i'll go shoot some hoops it's a good
time
hey where's
[Laughter]
let's have a good game out there fellas
you're going around challenging people
huh a little one-on-one huh
doing shirts and skins in a dave and
busters
yeah that's the dream we watched foley
assault a vr machine
we hooked him up to a vr machine after
about 18 martinis
dude he almost beat the poor waitress up
in the matrix he almost caught
i tell you what man i used to be anti-vr
hook me up to that thing and [ __ ]
get me a steady stream of mountain dew
code red i'm all right played star wars
and now i was in there still gaining
weight while on vr
in the virtual reality mcdonald's
you're waiting in the drive-through
goddamn traffic we got nobody working
here today what's going on
fantastic i could smell darth vader's
breath that's how [ __ ] oh you did the
you did that one were you in vegas
vegas wait where did you do that vr i
mean what do you guys like vr quarterly
what the [ __ ]
there was there's a you went to the dave
and busters in vegas
there's a there's a darth vader vr in
vegas that's like way too expensive but
it's fun as hell really yeah yeah yeah
and my buddy freaked out on it that's
how real it was is he like he like
freaked out
real tough guys
that ewok looked at me
no it was in uh it was in lovely
syracuse new york okay david buster's in
the mall there uh you fight darth vader
that was about it
he had a lightsaber i mean he played for
like two minutes
that was the craziest thing i've ever
taken part of
talked about it for three weeks
uh let's get into it you were mentioning
before off air yes that you happen to be
down in the city of brotherly love
that's philadelphia pennsylvania billy
baby what were you doing down here i was
at the helium uh for a little weekend
jaunt nice she burned it was a good good
time what a club what a town oh love it
good stuff i ate at wawa five times
five times and i like i felt like [ __ ]
the whole week oh it is you don't feel
good i had it i had it twice this
weekend breakfast and then a dinner and
yeah my god what'd you get i got a
cheese steak uh-huh i got a cheese steak
yeah yeah yeah i've never done that i
heard that's where the place to go
i was running late for a mega bus i was
like i gotta get a cheesesteak before i
get out of here i gotta get a
cheesesteak running late for a megabot
there was like rocky here
there was like 60 people at one of the
wah-wahs i had it was easter sunday yeah
and i had to leave
so
i got a cheesesteak i got a chicken
sandwich i got uh one of those pretzels
with like the cheese cheese yeah it was
dry as hell yeah and the heat lamp
you got to go with the traditional wawa
pretzels they have in the line there
they're usually pretty pretty moist okay
sometimes they get a little wet next
time which i don't know what that is
it's the salt brings it out of the
i didn't know they didn't sell beer at
wawa and so oh yeah late at night i felt
so bad because there's like a teen
working the front desk and i was all
give me the beers hammered
where you keep the booze where do you
get a beer around here and the girl's
like i don't drink all right
come on you want to get out of here it's
not the 1840s
you flip her a quarter
whiskey neat
dinner this is my favorite tavern this
is a good bar
hey there's a good bar do hot tits
hear your spurs table for one sugar tits
smoking if you got it
uh so anyway first night in uh in philly
it's thursday night thursday night the
host is like i'm going over to this
raven lounge right after the show the
world famous raven lounge where i met mr
h schmoly i remember it well yeah you
guys are legends of this room they were
all talking about you but wait really oh
no
no no no no no i think one person was
like yeah i think i think kev used to
come around here i think ken and harry
used to used to run this show
ken and harry
ah that's all right the ken and harry
show we are we are old people when we go
back there i mean think about it when i
started i was early 20s or whatever so
it was like
it's so it's all it's a very younger
group yeah you know yeah uh i go up
there they're like urging me to sit down
they're like please go sit up front i
was like i think i'm gonna be on the
show and they're like no we don't care
go sit on the front please all right
that's the thing where you have to
you have to make it look like it's
filled with audience members so a lot of
times they make the comic sit in the
audience yeah yeah so i never did that
yeah well
i'm busy meeting my guy in the alley
i wanted to preface i had a great time i
thought all the people were great great
fun
but they tell me i'm gonna go up last in
the like first group that's that's the
that's not creme de la creme they
actually had a headline in the first
half they were like hey i'm gonna put
you in the spot this will give you a
shot we're gonna give you this yeah
this is gonna be big for you
this is gonna change this might even get
back to ken and we've developed that
you're gonna be able to afford the
knicks after this you don't gotta go to
wawa that's the west coast offense right
there
put some dog at the end of the showcase
they go uh you're going up last so
that's like an hour and a half later
from when i get there but right still
sitting
[Laughter]
so finally right before they're like
you're up next or no they didn't even
tell me i was up there you're up in two
the guy who was supposed to be before me
is on and then the host i don't want to
name names and all people in this story
are good people sure yeah i know uh
right before i go so this guy who's up
before me gets off stage the host goes
on and makes fun of that guy's set he's
like you have the some nerve coming up
here doing some [ __ ] like that up
here uh it's all in good fun sure the
guy who's getting off stage does not
take it well real he goes well then stop
[ __ ] hitting me up to do my show and
then the host is like i you got to have
me on your show cause i'm a billion
[ __ ] times funnier than you you
aren't [ __ ] and this isn't just stage
[ __ ] i'm gonna tell you this when i get
off stage because it's not like that
here we go that's what i'm [ __ ]
talking about then he says
and here's your next comic tom's car
[Laughter]
give it up for this [ __ ]
i'll fight him too
so everybody leaves to go watch it
because he follows the guy right out and
it was that's awesome it was such a fun
like philly that is philadelphia
even though i got fired up again i love
that energy of like
me and chris cotton used to have literal
screaming matches from the dj booth
from the from the stage like like
father like [ __ ] mom and dad
screaming at each other
mid-show and then also that show used to
have the dj would have a mic yeah and
you could just like
interrupt people's sets
they were elected and waited like three
and a half hours to get on stage
you suck hell yeah it was
comedy needs that [ __ ] sometimes that's
fun yeah yeah i remember there was a kid
that came there
young kid i was nice to him uh
was it me
kind of balding
i had like a volleyball
um
and uh he had
horrible chapped lips like i mean
like university level
chap lips
and he got all i was hosting and and i
took him off stage and i made fun of his
chapped lips
killed
and he ran out and i never saw him again
that was me
he wished i was here yeah
i kind of do at times
that's good stuff we had a good time
it's a good place
shout out to the raven did you do any
city-wide specials down there wait
what's that city-wide specials you can
walk into like
the bar you said you're at drinkers and
just like any kind of bar and you get a
shot you get a paps and a shot of well
whiskey for five bucks ooh no one say
just give me the special oh no i didn't
i wish i hadn't known that before that
would have changed my whole time
he gets up and leaves my life goes right
back down there it's just a cloud of
smoke
uh yeah in the description be like hey
do you have the special and it's called
citywide because a lot of most of the
you know a lot of bars do it not i would
have been doing that too i was drinking
yinglings though it was a good little
hangers are all right you got to get
them in when you're down there you know
you have drinks at the raven you have a
couple of beers i had a couple i had a
couple nine dollar beer
yeah yeah that's the sort of thing
that'll that'll
all day the next day i was like eleven
dollars for a little whiskey huh that's
all right
get it back somewhere yeah
you strike me as a man who likes
reasonably priced alcohol yes i like it
i like it good i like a cheap i like it
in big bulk
i want a sam's club
look
[Laughter]
i want a bucket of beer
oh god that's great all right let's do
some cues yeah what do you say we got
tom here he's going to be answering your
question as you know when you sign up
for the old patreon you might be able to
get a question read on the air no you
will when you sign up for patreon if it
gets through kevin's rigorous screening
process can i say real fast i heard a
question that i that really i was
listening to the finance episode laying
on us and uh man the ques yeah
[Laughter]
uh there was a question that was like
have you ever gotten a haircut in a mall
and it triggered something in me i used
to get my hair cut at walmart what there
was a little salon at walmart and i'm
not kidding they used to have that like
stuff used to have that and it was the
best haircut i ever got
so good that it was this guy it was this
gay dude named duncan and he had long
beautiful hair
he would come here and when he left the
walmart one we followed him we said
we're going
there would be like a little like a
little boutique that had like two chairs
or whatever yeah you can go get your
hair done i don't remember that i
remember just going way back you guys
are too young for this but uh kmart had
a
diner in it what yep they had they had a
[ __ ] counter and they had uh stools
the whole nine yards they had like the
blue plate special
yeah and like one of my cousins her
aunts worked she was the waitress man
imagine being a waitress that it came
dynamite cleaned up really good it was
like i mean the savings yeah the savings
alone
twenty percent i don't pay a lot but the
cheap clothes are
never-ending um and then that got that
got shelved the transition into the into
the 80s from the 90s yeah then they
would have like there would be like a
pizza hut yeah they had little caesars
there when i was a kid and i loved
little caesars because of that i loved
little caesars in the 80s in the early
90s it was so the square pie they
[ __ ] did oh right they didn't they
weren't around when i was growing in my
area you couldn't get i left for a while
right what they like left for a while
yeah
that i'm not
i can't take them
i don't know it's one of those that if
i'm in a pinch i would do it but there's
just so much better pizza you know
i don't even know if i ever had it when
it came back i went twenty dollar eighth
and a hot and ready you guys didn't have
a childhood what are you talking about
hot readies didn't do it for me either
yeah there's something about it sitting
in that heat yeah it's not even that hot
or that ready
that one needs a couple more minutes 20
minutes
can't let's talk about athletic greens
ag-1 athletic green's best in a bit best
in the i can tell you why i started
taking athletic greens why is that big
guy i'm a big old fat piece of [ __ ] but
you're working on it but i'm working on
it's on your journey to get healthy yes
and athletic greens is a part of that as
you know i bring it to the gym with me
take taking during my workout making me
feel good powers me through it's like a
multivitamin that tastes delicious it's
like a super duper multivitamin they got
super duper duper 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole foods source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens
whatever they may or may not be the
other bozos don't even have 70.
that's 75. 75 over here um it's
lifestyle friendly whether you eat uh
keto paleo vegan dairy free or gluten
contains less than one gram of sugar no
gmos no nasty chemis or artificial
anything and it still tastes great as
the big man straight or gay doesn't
matter everybody can take everybody
helps better sleep quality recovery
supports mental clarity alertness it's
one of the best things that letter cream
uses the best of the best products based
on the latest science which is constant
with sounds like you need a little
athletic greens kevin
you ain't lying and to do so they made
it easy right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
and convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into cold and flu
season or out of it whatever just one
scoop and a cup of water every day
that's it no need for a million
different pill supplements uh
one stop shop uh athletic greens is
going to give you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase i use the vitamin d yesterday
and today no big deal all you have to do
is visit athleticgreens.com garbage
again that's athletic greens.com garbage
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance do it okay let's talk about
blue chew blue chew you know what i'm
talking about come on we all need a
little help from time to time i know i
do i know i do listen listen the blood's
not flowing the way it used to sure all
right my soldiers are out of practice
yeah they're on the bench oh man they
are on the bed they're third stringers
they got they're getting participation
trophies down here the point is
everybody needs a little help sometimes
all right blue chew is the help that you
want yes it's a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
a chewable tablets absolutely fraction
fraction of the price take them anytime
day or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready ready whenever the opportunity
arrives yeah you're trying to get laid
not poor you know what i mean
save a little money uh the process is
simple sign up at blue chew consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
a prescription within days the best part
it's all done online no weird doctor
visits grabbing your little gonads no
awkward combos no waiting in line at the
pharmacy and he knows what you're doing
by the way by the way i'm one of the
online therapists that you'd be talking
to
[Laughter]
video available got a little noodle blue
tablets are made in the usa and prepared
oh [ __ ] direct to your door in the
discreet package
um so right now as a special deal for
our listeners at ru garbage try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code garbage at checkout just pay five
bucks for shipping that's if you're
giving a product for free just pay for
shipping give it to you for free and
that's that's low shipping and handling
that's bluetooth.com promo code garbage
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com crazy more details and
important safety information we thank
bluechu for sponsoring his podcast back
to that show back to the show i've said
this before i don't mind a slice of
pizza to 7-eleven no it's crazy i mean i
ate it [ __ ] i ate one of those uh
twist roller things that the the tequila
yeah i ate a taquito on the way here i
can't believe you didn't know like the
tequila
a twist
they call them like twisters some of
them well they so there is there is like
the big roller there's like the meat
twister or something yeah i wanted to
call it
taquitos yeah i'll tell you what
you want to treat yourself this is the
old days i'm not doing this now just to
practice it you get yourself one of
those cheeseburger logs they have in
there
i'm telling you right now
they call them cheeseburger dogs no
bites
cheeseburger bites
so i've heard little chunks of cheese in
there
man maybe blow your hair back some of
them they do all i mean you know they
move a lot of product they know what
they're doing i've had wings there
before drunk yeah
i went back in for like second and third
really we were eating one of those
yeah we were eating on the hood of a car
he's asking to meet the chef
hey is louie still here by any chance
they just open a frozen bag there you go
yeah i've never tried the wings there oh
they're phenomenal the oysters are
unbelievable
fresh water
tower you gotta have the caviar
[Laughter]
i love a 7-eleven
oh they've gone to [ __ ] in the city
they're [ __ ]
it's awesome it's chaos in the city
anymore it's borderline
like you were saying about the about the
mega bus drivers they are not just
convenience store workers they are the
security they're social workers they're
doctors therapists they're therapists
and they're [ __ ] prison guards at
rikers i mean you walk into a place and
they got the soda locked up
i know you gotta hit it it's insane
legit the red the 7-eleven by the cellar
i'll have to have them get me a [ __ ]
red bull oh yeah well that one is that's
in the [ __ ] belly of the beast the
order around here is dicey oh man not to
mention we pulled him in the garage
today it looked like [ __ ] seattle it
was everybody on sub pop was out there
[ __ ] spiking up really dude
right
there there was five people just
shooting heroin on the street to get
something in the garage in the garage
what it's cold out what do you want
hey you gotta get your fix must be
awesome oh yeah the feeling when it hits
man i'd love to try it oh yeah let's do
it patreon
[Music]
it's kids this kid's got a business
savvy box what are we at right now we're
at like uh 3808 we hit 3809 i'm spiking
up you pull out you're joining right
away
did you keep your butter where's the
butter at oh my god
good time all right let's get into some
cues here
this is from uh so as the big man stated
when you join the patreon we will answer
your garbage question on the air
uh just the best way to do it patreon
gets first best crack at it of course i
do send one that comes across my radar
from another angle that tickles is fancy
and it's that good we'll use it of
course but we gotta we're working
through a bit of a backlog over there at
the old patreon they're jumping on the
fisher jumping on the boat over here at
patreon love it love it shout out to the
homies and the bozos um all right this
one is from chris first time long time
is it garbage to use a meat thermometer
[ __ ] meat thermometer
that's ian popped out my sermoner
holy [ __ ] score with a lot of chicks in
high school didn't you
got the captain of the football team
over here
mike you're meme in her
echoes right in your butthole doesn't it
[Laughter]
oh my god
holy [ __ ] gleepworm's back everybody
yeah i try to lincoln's a thermometer my
thermemeter
you know he can't wink right oh i saw
that
that was killing my head he's got a
shirt the new york times is terrifying
that's the picture they should use when
he dies
or if he gets canceled
oh yeah that's the one
local weirdo
not a lot around playgrounds anymore can
you wink uh
that's a great what the [ __ ]
i got it though
you're not closing any deals with that
you're no birthright i can tell you that
that's not bad i fix it i do have to do
the mouth thing though any other weird
thing what's your whistle situation
can't do it fingers
i throw up i'll throw up if i try that
if i do the thing i don't understand
where you're going
oh that's i've been doing it wrong
i put it in like a thermometer
limiters go over the top
or do you whistle with it under the
tongue i can't do it i can't whistle at
all i thought i could for a minute i was
doing that
i was like mommy i can whistle
good job
trying to keep a dog from attacking you
easy doesn't it
what is that like it's a new dance
i saw it
it's like a mashed potato isn't that
just where you spit
yeah it's like is that a talent i
thought it was an accident
you can do it on command it like shoots
from under the top i can do it on
command let me do it i mean i guess
i'm driving
oh i'm out i don't think that was i was
uh yeah no i'm double jointed is that in
there let me see
how far can you put your arm back oh
that's that
that's something i don't know
these are weird ones
this is some hillbilly ass [ __ ] where
you're like oh you can't do
all right let's get back to chris's
question all serious stuff [ __ ]
around all right
is it garbage to use a meat thermometer
as a regular one when you're sick
oh yeah yeah i don't even know how that
works i've done it i thought i could do
it with that big metal one that's like
this thick that you're putting like a
turkey jesus it starts at like 280 so
yeah you don't even register on it if it
pops you have a fever we would have done
that we never had a meat thermometer
that was all eyeballs yeah you gotta
eyeball your food yeah we have we had a
big metal one it was like an ice pick
yeah never had that and we had a regular
the regular last one i'd go the other
way i'd put the regular thermometer
this turkey needs to take a cool bath
these pork chops
we have to rush this thing to the
hospital
get your dental insurance card quick
the ambulance comes who's sick the pot
roast
um that was very 80s
regular thermometer
you had just the glass one right yeah
yeah did anybody at any point or do you
currently have like the
we've recently just got a digital one
yeah i got a digital my mom has the gun
really yeah like a bouncer well they got
they got real cheap over the pen they
were like
started cranking them out one of those
guns i don't know how to use them
there's no way that they're accurate no
all right yeah i remember when they i
remember when the ear came out
yeah yeah and the year one came out
because to be honest with you
my mother was strictly anal is that
right most of my child
how'd she have you
that's why it's so big
a little a little ran down
that's why he's so big
you can't put a magnifying glass on some
of these
light speed
i remember the first time she did it it
was very uncomfortable
we're in a dog fight right now and she
she strapped it on
i don't know what the poppers were doing
there should we put a skirt on it was
weird
um wait really we never did that never
in the butt i don't think you should no
and and not not i think it's more
accurate they say because it's in you
right yeah it's like
i'm sick or i'm not sick
i need it i need a note or not yeah you
[ __ ] point three degrees whatever it
feels like it's gonna be isn't it hotter
down there anyway it feels like it'd be
high i mean i would assume my butthole
runs a little higher if i'm i don't put
my if i've been if i've been dancing
after a night of molly and [ __ ]
dancing on the floor yeah
of course it is
it's a party back there
it's just it's it's not the act of it
because you know i'm all for it you know
what i mean sure i get freaky deaky but
your mom doing it was weird do you
remember that i think that's the thing
you shouldn't remember oh i yeah dude
i'm telling you she did it way too long
i would say 10 maybe 20 minutes ago
[Laughter]
she does it every time i go home
[Laughter]
[Music]
but you're kind of a classy person if
you have one of those that's true that's
true i'm surprised that a human being
has a meat thermometer not a regular
thermometer yeah that might never break
each other's a thermometer yeah
the government or something right
there's like mercury in there right the
mercury running in your hand
no yeah was that bad isn't that doesn't
it burn through your hand or something
scary poisoning it's like horrible no it
just floats around in your hand a little
bit really yeah try this at home so good
that's it yeah google this tobe yeah are
you googling it on your phone
uh yeah we had to re-upload the episode
because it didn't take ah gotcha
nice take that
youtube youtube
um all right let's see here we'll back
to t-bone in the information corner in a
minute uh
this is from android never had one red
anyone anyone you know refer to their
jeans as dungarees
we were a big dungaree's house really
yeah my dad was that's a nice pair of
dungarees
wearing my dumbbells he would get them
dry cleaned
he would get his dungarees
are those like nicer pants no they were
levi's
i don't know where dungarees come from
you're going a little caesars make sure
you wear your nicer pants yeah
dungarees is whack those those are thick
jeans that don't fit well or brutal
dungarees why do they call them
dungarees it derives from the hindi word
dungaree denoting a heavy coarse durable
cotton twill woven from colored yarns
dungaree eventually became
for specific blue denim trousers from
the late 1800s i thought it would be
more western
yeah well i was i was full i don't think
in australia really i was going austin
if you're saying an accent if it brings
you through your
got your dungarees on do you mate
ready to fight the kangaroo that was on
dungarees
[Laughter]
we had slacks we did slacks we call them
slacks yeah put on a nice pair of slacks
yeah but we there was always a fight
when it was always a big thing when we
had to go out and buy a pair i gotta
take them and get a pair of chinos
shirts golf shirts we would wear like we
we call them polo polo yeah we call them
golf shirts yeah and a nice golf shirt
put it with kennedy dirt bag i think
it's trashier
that's a golf shirt named after a small
bowling shirt would be more
just the same shirt i guess
is button yeah yeah and your names on it
i really wish that they would slightly
come back bowling shirts yeah like what
uh charlie sheen wore on two and a half
yeah yeah that is you at your peak i
feel like well
you you know bring it back uh this isn't
a fat joke by any means you are big
enough to wear whatever you wear
the size it's just like kind of zany it
works bad guys can get away with stuff
because you know what i mean
tuxedo
look at this goofy [ __ ]
you're just fat ass wacky guy you're
getting married today
he wore that
playing basketball in a tuxedo
i'm just saying you can you know it's
you know it's not weird just yeah
i know and i i push that a little you do
and that's why i'm saying it yeah of
course
i don't know though those seem
i feel like if i wore that on stage i
would always bomb because it's so hack
to wear that shirt plus my materials
[Laughter]
those feel so like kramer shirts oh sure
yeah i love the kramer shirt that's why
i wear like the thing that i wore
the the purple one i got the my rant
shirt but i got ranch all over
oh yeah he's been referring to a shirt
that he stained
i was imagining like a cowboy
chipotle ranch
on a tuner sandwich
out there
someone get my mayo pants
[Laughter]
my mayo dungarees
i wore it on the josh potter show ooh
fantastic episode um
uh i got you i got your line on the
mercury situation let's go all right
this is a warning that reads more like a
challenge
elemental mercury does not does absorb
through your skin but at a very slow
pace parentheses varies very slowly like
they basically call you a [ __ ] for not
handling mercury
no no as long as you don't expose your
skin to the metal too much and wash your
hands after that
you're fine yeah shut up it's like a
good time or not you party or don't you
what's this on barstool where'd you get
this
vice article
it's feidelberg's
dr john feidelberg saying that
[Laughter]
um all right let's see this one's from
rudy if you get challenged to a foot
race are you doing it with your shoes on
or shoes off wow which i think if you're
ever
if you're in a situation where you're
being challenged to a foot race and you
accept that's trash regardless of what
right i've done this happens to me a lot
everybody wants a piece of the king me
and my buddies it's lonely at the top
no this happens to me a lot i i deal
with a lot of challenges a lot of
push-up challenges
challenging you like buddies
yeah or just you know a
guy at a bar
i bet i could beat you in a race a cop
though it's buddies when we're drinking
i saw you from across the bar you look
like you think you're fast
yeah came in here wearing track shoes
you look like you think you're faster
than you are that's a specific look you
could beat me
um what was it is there any crazy
challenge that you've done have you ever
been hurt
from boozing and doing something stupid
climbing a tree trying to jump over
playing basketball it's just [ __ ] house
because there's a court right outside of
my apartment and on my birthday last
year a buddy was like let's go
i bet uh it's it started with like i bet
you anything i'll make a free throw
and you won't yeah and he missed and
then i was like double it and i'll make
one
[ __ ] and then we played one-on-one in
dress shoes and both got [ __ ] fell
over and heard are we wearing dress
shoes it's my birthday come on man but
you were just hanging out at your
apartment i'm not gonna change shoes to
go outside also he was in dress shoes he
can't wear my shoes that wouldn't be
fair yeah but why are you in dress shoes
just in your apartment well i was ups i
was i was on the roof
was there a gala happening
look if it's my birthday
this is an event
the pigeons have a strict dress code up
there
oh i was on the roof i like how you
tried to explain in each turn i didn't
get it yeah no i'm not going to wear you
know i
it's my birthday party did you have a
birthday party there was people there oh
yeah you didn't just dress up by
yourself no i don't want to just have a
cigar by myself on my roof another year
gone
make your own cake
[Laughter]
so you had a nice party up on top of the
water yeah yeah yeah you go up there a
lot uh yeah it's a nice little roof are
you allowed to be up there that's a good
question that's where i feel like you're
not allowed it's connected to our
apartment so i feel like it's someone
else's roof it's all it's our roof it's
our roof but it's the building's roof
how do you say it's connected like
there's two doors
[Laughter]
so it has another entrance to get out
there
so you could literally wake up and look
at your window and there's people that
happened well somebody tried to break
into our bedroom door by they snuck up
uh on the roof i wasn't home i'm
terrified out of there yeah we almost
moved but uh we had him we fought with
him to put an alarm on the on that one
door so it's a crazy fight with somebody
to be like hey man someone tried to
break in here can you still new york
baby they're like well it doesn't really
matter
nice dress shoes in here
[Laughter]
say this say it
running in bare feet as a young man
felt awesome on the grass and i felt
faster
all during my lacrosse career in college
i never wore socks
on my cleats because i felt like i was
faster it was freeing on concrete
liberating liberating if you will sure
no underwear either
[Laughter]
[Music]
but i feel like that's a very dirt bag
thing let me take my shoe it's taking
off your shirt in a fight yeah yeah
every time you're removing something
it's not it's not a great look and
you're losing yeah as we've we've
covered yeah you take your shirt off i
feel like that's not a manly like women
do that literally i got to take my heels
off over to fight but a man taking his
shoes off is very strange i don't want
to see a barefoot a bear man's foot in
public unless you know karate right then
it's cool then it comes back around yeah
yeah
still probably getting your eyes you're
still getting your ass kicked i feel for
sure
one way hey hold on i know karate i need
to take your shoes off
you changed into the whole karate outfit
that's great um all right let's see this
is from sean mullen first time ever
refill empty bottles of water with tap
water and put them back in the fridge
always i'm probably going to do that
with this one yeah
oh man you really know the difference
this i feel like will taste right this
will be really yeah yeah yeah it's
better than i don't like drinking warm
tap water i don't like using ice when i
can save it and so i like to what are
you doing for spirit oh for uh
what do we have guests um
break out the good ice how many ice
trays do you have in your freezer oh we
got
two red i got two regular they match and
then i have a set of like uh the
cocktail big square big squares and some
the orbs
yeah during the pandemic i got into
making uh uh cocktails
i feel it was just like pop off vodka on
ice it's mostly uh
cherry coke zero
that's your drink it's good i just got
into it it's very good really i just got
into it i've discovered formula one yeah
what uh what kind of rum we talking oh
cappy maybe yeah that was really good uh
everybody was doing captain and cokes
was like the big thing but captain and
ginger
interesting like no it dude
it's all no one's raised they had at the
the cellar party they had captain and
ginger was it yeah i don't know if i had
i think i had a captain in coke that's
when they were giving them around it was
all right the captain of ginger and
ginger it's like cream sickly yeah it's
got the spiced rum it's got the ginger
pretty good what's the captain of coke
called the other thing
that's called something a rock and
roller or something like that no i'm
telling you has another name it might be
the cuban word for it what's the cuban
phrase for captain and coke
i don't know i'm going to start calling
that's cherry cokes and rum to car
crushers no no no i can't take credit
for it it's called the kelpie courts
came up with this drink i can't take
credit for it what the the cherry coke
and throat came up with it he made it
sound like there's a lot of money on the
line
i can't take crap i don't want to get
sued he wasn't in a lab i don't want to
get
somebody has to come up with this [ __ ]
hey man you took credit for my drink
we're racing you got to take your shoes
off you got to come up with like a
mountain dew based drop shot so you can
call it the car bomb oh
you know what would be good have you
ever had those not your father's
mountain dews
no they have the night your father's
root beers they're like alcoholic
spiders yeah they make uh not your
father's mountain dew is it in a can
like it's a bottle
yeah yeah and it's uh if you dropped
like vodka in that and chugged it i bet
it would taste [ __ ] terrible but
it would get you drunk
it'll do the job
it'll have you shooting foul shots
outside
oh man do one of those tag are you
garbage we will post that [ __ ] yeah i
want to think of a better one now damn a
real one that we could do
i'll come up with one and then we'll
we'll do one we'll do it
on the patreon mostly i just drink
whiskey or just kill your buddy to keep
them quiet that's good run with the
[ __ ] folks that's yeah that's what a
pro would do yeah yeah yeah you're a
shot i'm a shot and beer kind of guy as
well yeah
yeah popping a little uh whiskey and a
pbr or like i'm a high life man
real it's not everywhere i guess in
brooklyn it's probably more readily
available the bar i go to in my
neighborhood it's uh they do it's called
a low life and it's uh you can do a
whiskey and highlife it's great yeah
what's that five bucks
brooklyn where do you live in the 1960s
cold high life in the summer
that's where that's oh
i'm gonna have one later
[Laughter]
i don't think you need a lot of
convincing to be honest no no i was i
was on the up and up
i've been sober for 10 years
i was drinking with you less than a week
i was drunk
i didn't remember
[Laughter]
always so that alcohol took advantage of
me
we both bonded uh at the seller party
over we both were like
we're not i'm like i'm not even really
drinking tonight and like we were both
on our ninth beer
drinking if i don't wake up hungover i'm
not drinking and i did wake up oh yeah
i was pretty [ __ ] up
yeah you're drinking ginger ale and
[ __ ] it was so much sugar i but my
thought was like i didn't start drinking
until like 11 30. so you can't get in
too much trouble yeah and then i was
there till five
maybe four i think i got home at five
damn got home at five take the train uh
no not that late
but you know yeah i gotta take it i
wanna see how crazy he was
i've done it before i fall asleep if i
do that and now if you take the i take
the ac you got to switch to a bus
oh half of it i fell asleep on the butt
last time i did i fell asleep on the bus
they had to wake me up and the depot
yeah
yeah i work there now
i had to pick up a shirt
i can't believe i've never gotten robbed
on the train with how much i fall asleep
on it i woke up out in coney i live all
the way up they just skip over here
ain't got no nothing
nothing but bourbon
but yeah that was a big thing where i'm
like if i don't six beers isn't drinking
which is a problem
no you're good
says the guy with dental with you come
on yeah
i'm good
did you feel a little empowered when you
got dental insurance yeah i feel like
you got a little safety throwing in
people's faces
i don't need this i had to upgrade it
because everywhere i would take it they
were like oh this doesn't do anything it
doesn't do it it was like 15 bucks a
month and it was they were like oh yeah
this doesn't even cover the cleaning i
don't know what it did i had to upgrade
it dental insurance is one of the
biggest scams that's why i had my wisdom
teeth taken out that was it was worth it
for so it covered that yeah because
that's about what like 1500 tooth it can
be it can be crazy and it only cost me
like 300 bucks i think to get two of
them out and i got the gas it only cost
me 14.50 you shouldn't they shouldn't
tell you how much the gas costs they
were like it's like an extra 150 bucks
if you want to get the gas i brought my
own dude yeah
with a huge balloon don't worry i'm
going to hold this mercury
cooking uh do you like the gas uh the
gas was good i got some to go i got a
let's get a ziploc bag
you fill this up
can i get a roadie
i got a growler i guess
did they give you a little something to
take the edge off over the next couple
of days i did but i'm not a pain pill
guy so uh interesting let's talk after
the show
are they still on your person
uh i uh they're not on my person
no i uh i
decided i might see me on your roof
later tonight trying to break in
the problem is you can't drink with the
pain pills that's not true that's what
they say yeah
they scared me about that that legit
because i already
you know test the waters a little too
much with how much i drink so it's like
i don't want to do severe liver damage
but you know sure that makes sense
what are you talking about
when you said that i did just have a
flash of when we were talking you had
two of those rum and cokes in your hands
drinking problems and he's got two
plastic cups
but i never take tylenol when i'm
drinking
that would be crazy
advil no thank you look i like to take
care of my body into my temple or
whatever your head too
one of each flavor
yeah that's that's an old wife i also
had a whiskey on the side
because you had to go all the way down
to the bar to get that and then they
were walking around with trays of the
rubbing coats or whatever
once there's a free thing going
he's just following her around i'm
losing money not to drink
i love it buddy we're having fun over
here this one i've never thought of this
is from the milkman of the midwest first
time long time is it garbage to keep a
cafeteria tray in the car so you can eat
while driving without making a mess
whoa that's crazy that's
genius yeah i've never heard of it
probably on your lap and then you just
yeah it goes on to your lap
that's right you're not worried about
spilling it's like you have one of the
airplane seats yeah
that's a good idea
yeah think about if it's under your lap
it's under the steering wheel it's not
in the way yeah i mean it is garbage for
sure oh yeah yeah sure how did you get
it that's the thing that's you gotta you
gotta [ __ ] sneak into a school don't
worry it's not for creepy [ __ ] it's for
uh it's for fat guys stuff science
hey kid come here you want to make a
couple bucks you can steal one from my
[ __ ] burger king mcdonald's oh
anywhere not any fast food places well
he said cafeteria though that makes sure
it's a child's hospital maybe oh yeah
well you know fast food places have just
yeah oh yeah they have changed for here
to go ah for you there you go you gotta
feel like a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
walking out of a burger king with the
train snuck under your [ __ ] shirt
yeah i got washboard abs
oh god that that's what it is that's
great though i mean that's something the
listeners i will feel start doing i
think that's gonna because that's like
that's next level
thought process that i would have never
thought of a garbage tree man that's
good i want to know if he stole it for
that reason or if he just ended up with
one
and was like oh this is perfect i mean
how do you just end up with i don't know
man you'd be surprised yard sale
somebody had to get it the first time
yeah
i would say what he did is he walked in
and he said i don't know maybe a
grandmother died
they said for here to go and he said for
here right and then just walk and then
he's but he's sneakily meant to go yeah
maybe he works at mcdonald's or
something oh that's that's good goes
right to the supply either way very
smart but very very very trash that's
really good yeah i might do that plus
you're not you're eating in the car
because i eat taco bell in my car a lot
and that's so messy but with a tray
think about it right
it's not bad and your your pants are
clean
yeah and you don't have to be so like
conscientious of where you know you
can't drive and eat though that's why
are you like washing the tray what do
you do with the tray you just dump it
out the window
the birds will take care of it
that tray is covered in blunt guts and
bad weeds yeah yeah uh a guy i know used
to do
[Laughter]
he used uh he would have a frisbee in
the car
to roll blunts on because it was curved
like he would roll it on the inside that
way if you're bouncing or whatever
nothing falls out like because you hit
the break something it slips i i
remember he showed me that i'm like why
the [ __ ] do you have a frisbee a [ __ ]
and he's like you roll blunts on him
like oh my god people are getting these
ideas for free that's crazy
this is crazy
there's true genius out there that's
wild i'm learning a lot man gotta get
somebody on research and development
over here
um all right let's see this speaking of
dave and buster's is from devon is it
garbage i got my waffle maker using
tickets at a dave and buster's geez that
is just good that's good business man
you're you're investing walking out a
winner yeah how many tickets do you have
that's got to be a lot awful it's got to
be a lot but like
high quality waffle making why get a one
i wouldn't i mean i'm sure there's a
list of
50 things i would take before a waffle
maker yeah also waffle maker is one of
those things that i don't know if you
guys are black friday shoppers like me
but that's one of those you're getting a
waffle maker for five dollars if you
want it you know yeah like that's what
i'm saying like unless it's like a
[ __ ]
swiss made waffle maker how many times
do you use that how many watts another
thing i'm sure you could have got a tv a
cool [ __ ] some sort of cool
electronics when's the last time you had
a watch tv for the same price that it's
a waffle
i don't know well what's a waffle maker
costume it's gotta be a lot that's what
i'm saying i bet i want to know how much
you spent in like
at david
buying the [ __ ] to get a couple hundred
bucks i would imagine i bet you that's
like 500
worth of playing games to get that's a
while maybe a grand that could have been
spent in the vr too yeah yeah you know
i don't know if i'm gonna get an answer
i tried seeing how many tickets it was
yeah i got nothing yeah there's no way
that's coming up oh they're really
pushing this chicken and waffles though
they got cooking over there dnb i can't
believe they have dude i want to go to
dave and buster
now is there one in the city i think
there is one yeah there's one in times
square yeah there's one in times square
yeah
that'd be a fun patreon yeah that's a
good time dude a bunch of us just at
dave and buster's hanging boozing at the
olive garden hammered in the [ __ ] day
if we bring tom and we get him to
challenge pete random people at the
david busters that's a [ __ ] video it
is my goal it's like if i don't leave
with the record on the papa shot thing i
feel like a [ __ ] failure i feel like
a loser i think if you leave with it
you're still a failure but
it's just calling balls and strikes
take my dental insurance and leave
i was going to be treated like this i'll
be eating taco bell in my car if anybody
cares all right tom to carr versus the
field
busters where are you putting your catch
let's go i mean it's got to go with me
has he been drinking
[Laughter]
that's a fun video that we could do on
the patreon just it's in the city it's
easy we can just go we'll do a dinner at
like [ __ ] applebee or fridays or
something hell yeah we'll take you out
for a night in the town let's go baby
let's go
wear your dress shoes
you have to wear your dress shoes and
then offer to raise somebody and take
them off oh man that's going to be tough
i don't have a shoehorn taking them off
yeah
how am i going to get them back
all right let's see we got a couple more
here
this is uh from david dave i feel this
never had a question about this i feel
this has tom all over it have you have
you or anyone you know ever been to a
backyard wedding oh yeah yeah i guess
absolutely i've been multiple yeah yeah
big indiana honestly they're kind of fun
like cause you can get a big keg it's a
good time yeah and
uh
half of them have uh
worked for more than a year sure i don't
think it's yeah it's not one that
normally lasts the odds aren't your
favor yeah but i have and it depends on
i've definitely been to a park wedding
too or it's like there's they don't have
they shouldn't be doing it probably
proper permits yeah yeah yeah they're
cooking on the grills yeah
yes yeah i've done that um got doorknobs
on their registry
hey we need paper thousands of houses
those overhangs they have at the parks
you know what i mean
dude i went to a dry one of those and i
was pissed that's like the worst thing
you could do to somebody yeah that's
it's tough man it's just tough dry
wedding is brutal
i don't care yeah make it byob why was
it a dry wedding because they didn't
drink or just money
it was a
little from a column a little like they
were like you shouldn't even bring like
it was it was a religious ass
i don't think i've ever been to a dry
wedding [ __ ] now i'm out don't worry i
know if i've been to a cash ball don't
worry i went up a little bit
i
[Laughter]
he came out the night before and buried
some beers
i was just talking to brian morton about
that i was just about to say brian
morton was telling us about that's old i
was like from like a year that was maybe
not a year ago that's an old thing
though yeah he sent that in chicago
yeah they his boys buried booze i heard
about this that went viral music
festivals music festival yeah yeah yeah
yeah
showed up a week later or you know
during the thing yeah dug it up that is
genius except for now every music
festival i go to i'm just going to be
digging holes everywhere like well you
can't bring a shovel in here
i got a pickaxe a miner's hat
i'm not even watching the bands i just
wanted to drink it here sorry your
bloodhound's gonna have to wait outside
there are no metal detectors allowed
please
it's got a treasure map
you just tell me what they do north is
oh god who has a compass on them
that's trash backyard wedding never been
i've only ever been to weddings in
traditional places definitely some like
non-traditional but it was still matrix
it would have been like at the
venue like not a church moving at the
venue
outside or you know what i mean
something
nice never trashy it was always
done well you're talking like somebody's
house yeah
wow somebody was telling us i just went
to one in a barn that was like in the in
the back of my buddy's house it was fun
yeah did he live here
uh yeah or he ran at the barn no he
lived there in the barn he's a horse
uncle head or whatever her mr head
because his wife's a coke
no it was barn wedding he's a horse my
buddy josh cox
[Laughter]
you know my buddy here comes sunshine
he was the best man
biscuit
get a choice of oats or hay
i went with the hay
it was a nice time
[Laughter]
oh we're having fun here
this one's not even a question this is
from official garbage inspector my
mother-in-law hassles me for for free
weed
that's just not the classiest of
statements ever no wow that's tough um
doing any kind of drugs with that for
the parent tough yeah even just smoking
weed so i've i've smoked with someone
else's parents and that's a great time
um i never even enjoyed that really
it's just weird the line i'm waiting for
it to go south
for them to freak out i think it's gotta
weed is as far as if we're doing ecstasy
with what your [ __ ] grandma it's not
like it's not a good night
mr johnson's rolling his brains
yeah i'm always waiting for it to get
weird because those old heads they go to
a wedding they get a couple in them they
think it's [ __ ] groovy time they're
back in laurel canyon or the 60s or
something they get two toys
yeah i can barely [ __ ] handle it
right now yeah
next you know they're freaking out
ruining the wedding get over here like
hey relax
wacko
[Laughter]
then the wife catches him what are you
doing bill uh-huh that's a big thing too
living my life [ __ ] everybody smokes
cigs at weddings
so it's like i'm and i just i'm the only
one in my family who just like kind of
there's a lot of us but just blatantly
smoking cigarettes and then at a wedding
everybody's like having pops and then
sure i'm going out and then i'm the
[ __ ] who's just like giving all of
these nonsmokers they're like he's out
there smoking with kevin i'm like
[ __ ]
i started smoking cigars at weddings so
that i wouldn't ask people for their
cigs oh that's pretty good yeah yeah
because you get the fix you're out there
because it is the social you want to be
more annoying i like it what the hell
i'm not asking for anything
[Laughter]
you smoked the whole thing at once yeah
so you go out and you smoke
what are you gone for two hours that
party
we were smoking about the
old fda
too much yeah but uh
drill it in reel it in
no yeah it out let's look at the cigar
so you're going to be sick but it's good
but doesn't it take an hour to smoke
totally because it's not like a bernie
you're not right yeah yeah like you're
getting everybody's hanging yeah yeah
i only smoke them with verbs that's the
only time i'll smoke them is with ferzie
that's yeah i don't like it's but even
when i'm smoking them i'm like all right
let me put this out and go outside and
smoke it yeah i prefer
i'm like that's just i'm like can you
take a break from a cigar
have a smoke pack a lip
i'll get back to this in a couple of
minutes uh anybody got a jewel on them
they're used to feeling good all the
time
that's great that's crazy that's my
favorite creature yeah
yeah he's a funny guy we gotta you
should have him on the show michael
richards no kramer character
i would have them on in a second you
know that sweater they used twice that
was the sweater episode oh made the guy
sneeze
the lady who ran the uh unemployment
office her daughter who george dated
yeah yeah also wore that sweater
god that episode's so funny what a fun
fact for you gang oh great episode i
hear you're getting older
uh don't say his name we don't need to
be sued no um all right this is uh from
twenty dollar homie yeah you know me
never had one read og 20. uh
doubling up on parties wife's family had
an easter plan turned into an easter
slash gender reveal party second
marriage catered by the olive garden oh
and then on the way out they asked for
20 bucks ahead shut the [ __ ] up
i was like shyamalan wrote that thing
dude that is insane i see third parties
on the way out that is that's bamboozled
yeah that i would have never [ __ ] i
would never that's insane an easter
affair catered by the olive garden
then they do a gender reveal which i'm
out right there i'm leaving yeah they
grow second marriage i don't like a
gender reveal party listen i don't mind
the [ __ ] oliver i'm not [ __ ] on
the olive garden rules
i mean but like olive garden catered
like i wouldn't want to pay for i think
holidays are sunday i probably got it
today ahead of time oh i should probably
open them
that's [ __ ] great i love that that's
like a friendship ender like you're
charging me 20 on the way that yeah on
the way if you want to say like hey we
paid i would have rather been like they
come to me before and i'll pay for the
whole thing yeah and i'm
disrespectful to ask me for 20 that is
crazy i wonder how they did it
hey by the way
breadsticks ain't free yeah yeah well i
think they are
and they're never ending
everyone has a buzzer
everyone's got a buzzer when their
parmesan's ready
that is [ __ ] crazy that is some
trashy anything like that will really
turn me off
yeah and it's if you just say up front
like if you put that in the invite like
hey if people want to chip
20 for whatever of course yeah yeah yeah
yeah could you imagine going to a family
party and they charge you that's insane
it's like that's why you bring stuff
yeah hey every that's fine hey everybody
makes something you make meatballs you
make the [ __ ] if you're hosting you're
probably you're losing some [ __ ]
money all right that's part of the deal
yeah yeah yeah that's part of the deal
that's crazy you have plenty of money to
buy the [ __ ] baseball with the blue
dyeing it right
or the pinata whatever the [ __ ]
all right olive gardens catering your
event 8 to 14 people what's it going to
run you per person or total total eight
to 14 people olive garden cater 200
bucks
yeah i think it's i'm gonna go 300. i'm
gonna go
can i prices write them sure
you kippy is the closest it is a hundred
and eighty nine dollars for 14 people
wow
that's a good ass deal that's crazy he's
on the phone with olive garden i'm
losing money not to have my days catered
by
paying 14.99 for an entree like an
[ __ ] you just get it tonight just
have leftovers for the next three weeks
he's charging 20 ahead so he's not only
[ __ ] he's making money he's making
money off his family [ __ ] god what a
piece of man crazy dirt bags all right
we got a wrap guy all right gang we love
you tom we love you i love you boys what
do you got coming up you want the gang
out there yeah yeah plug away
yeah listen to his pots stand by your
band yes yes and if uh if you yeah
follow me on everything it's tom takara
it's spelled like thacker with 2ks uh if
in case you're not formerly tom brady
yes um but i will be in little rock
arkansas next weekend for a gender
reveal yes for an olive garden gender
reveal party
i'll be at uh indianapolis helium in may
i'll be um
in boulder colorado all my dates will be
on my website tomtoccar.com and then uh
yeah get on that get on that uh patreon
for our podcast yeah do it absolutely
[ __ ] awesome love you boys thanks so
much for having me we love you buddy
gang make sure you check out our patreon
obviously we're going to be traveling
all around the country here this summer
it's going to be a good time uh i
believe chicago is coming up right tacos
coming up uh first show sold out second
tickets for
uh old town second show available now
and there's still some tickets left at
rosemont get them before they're gone
denver
you salt lake city phoenix
it's good stuff yeah and we're looping
back around pittsburgh buffalo detroit
we're coming baby we love it we're sorry
we missed you yes gang we'll see you
next week